hello--hi you have your finger on the
pulse of the industry tonight welcome to
Hollywood's most glamorous night of
nights the professional golf Oh
Producers Guild of America Awards awards
season is in full swing and the 2020
Producers Guild Awards are not one to
miss a movie is not just the person who
acts in it or the person who wrote it or
the person who produced it it's the
little people like me but nobody ever
ating the finest producing work of the
year Octavia Spencer Marta Kauffman
Netflix's Ted sir and OHS the film
bombshell and Brad Pitt along with Dede
Gardner and Jeremy kleiner of plan B
will receive special honors but the
award to keep an eye on is the coveted
producer of the Year award in theatrical
motion pictures the award is often a
strong indicator who will win Best
Picture at the Oscars in fact since the
producers guild awards started in 1990
this award has accurately predicted 21
of the 30 winners of the Academy Award
for Best Picture let's take a closer
look at the nominees 1917 Ford versus
Ferrari
the Irishman Jojo rabbit Joker knives
out little women marriage story once
upon a time in Hollywood and parasite
economies action the only film in this
category not nominated for Best Picture
at the Oscars is knives out you guys
fans I mean I don't do much fiction
reading myself
big fan in addition to recognizing film
The Producers Guild Awards the best of
the best in television and leaves no
stone unturned episodic limited series
non-fiction live shows sports children's
gaming competition and short form
programming are
all categories for the producers guild
and new to the award show this year the
producers guild will recognize VR AR and
more experiential mediums via their
innovations award where a means to an
end but now winners will be announced
during the 31st annual producers guild
awards on Saturday January 18th at the
Hollywood Palladium
[Music]